Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 5th,
2014 Cinco de Mayo,
everybody happy.
Cinco de Mayo to all a Mexican listeners
and a white people and everybody else
who just wants to go out and get shit
faced tonight. Uh, for whatever reason.
So you haven't excuse tomorrow when
you drag an ash. Yeah, no real sure.
A that up to your level of productivity
that we're used to here at Cogswell
cubs. And he'd be like, well, fuck you.
I went out and I celebrate last night.
What's the matter?
You don't like Mexicans there you go off.
One of the few times a white person can
use the race card. Just slam that fucker.
Write down, are you against Mexico? Well,
how right then kindly remove
yourself from my cubicle area.
All right.
I got drunk last night for America.
Um, oh, here's one for your last night.
I was hanging out with Jason Law had,
you know, obviously race has
been a huge fucking split,
a huge topic of interest over
the last couple of days. Um,
I was over a Jason Law heads, uh, place.
He's got this apartment bill has
got a really cool rooftop and uh,
and I get to Cla,
get to see the helicopters fucking
with their spotlights down on some poor
bastard trying to run away.
I don't know how I feel about police
helicopters out here or just in general.
I mean,
I'm all for catching the bad guys,
but it does kind of get to
the point of like, you know,
how much fucking help do you need here?
You guys already have your,
you guys are all on the same
team. You'll have uniforms. Okay.
It's like 900 cop cars to one cop
car. You're all on the radio. Hey,
just made a right on fucking sunset.
You need a helicopter to lighten
the guy up. Jesus Christ.
How long would Bonnie and Clyde last
in this day and age,
you couldn't fucking get away with,
what am I defending right now?
Homicidal maniacs, I guess I am.
There's just something about like,
you know,
so like when you watch a
cowboy and Indian movie,
you've got to root for the underdog.
You Go, you go for the Indians.
I guess the native Americans is that
when they call them now, am I in trouble?
Do I have to apologize?
Um,
yeah,
yeah. He always root for the
fucking underdogs. So I look at it,
I ain't, what the fuck I'm saying? So when
he was, so we're up on this roof and um,
as we walk up on the roof, there's
already some people partying up there. Um,
and they're celebrating Cinco de Mayo,
mostly Mexican people.
I think up there playing the music and all
that shit, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Everything's fine. So me and lie
ahead and a bunch of white guys,
we go up there and then we sit down on
these other chairs and we start smoking
cigars.
And then all of a sudden one of
the dude's comes walking over.
He'd been drinking and they
had like, you know, these,
these potted plant bushes and the dude's
walking over to an area where there is
no exit. And then he walks
behind the bushes and we're like,
is he going to Piss over there? So one of
the guys that were with goes, he's like,
Yo, Yo dude, that's not a bathroom
man, that's not a bathroom.
And the guy stayed down
there for a minute.
So then we go back to talk and in our
cigars and then I hear him talking to his
friends and you'll bro,
that's not a bathroom.
And then I hear, oh, we got your
back, we got your back. Right.
I'm sitting there going, Oh God,
here we go and here we go. And a,
so then I'm thinking like
maybe he wasn't pissing.
So that's why he's mad.
And then he's looking at us going like,
all those white guys already didn't like,
it's up here with our music.
And now we assumed just because
I walk behind these bushes,
then I was taking a fucking pissed and
maybe I was just looking down over the
side of the building to see if
my friend was showing up. Right.
So that's what I'm thinking is playing
out in my head. So long story short,
he's fucking, you know, a couple of
mean muggin looks over our way. And, uh,
so I'm already thinking in my head how
to verbally talk the whole situation
down. Basically doing the exact opposite
of what a bouncer does. You know,
where they, their security, but
they always escalate the situation.
Remember that story told a while back or
I saw two guys almost got into a fight
in the bounces, fucking break
them up and okay, hey, hey,
you know what's going on here?
And this guy goes, well this guy,
and he kind of put his hand on the box
of shoulder and the bouncer goes, okay,
first of all,
don't touch me.
And immediately fucking escalated it
now rather than he was coming over to,
to diffuse it, he was escalating it. So I
was sitting there going like, all right,
out of fuck,
am I going to fucking conveyed to them
honest mistake if to stu wasn't pissing,
you know, I mean, what the fuck are
we supposed to think? You're drinking,
you stumbling over, you walk behind
bushes on the roof, you know,
to me that is classic.
I'm drunk and I'm going to Piss
the first place I can find, you know,
no cover. I mean cover I should say,
nobody could see me is what I should
say. So, um, long story short,
uh, this black dude comes over who's
gay? This is like a fucking reality show.
You know,
where they get what all we need is an
Asian guy and somebody with a sassy
attitude. And I think I have
a hit show here, you know? Um,
so he comes over and
he's like, yeah, sorry.
I don't even know he's gay,
but he has like the gay accent,
which I guess is homophobic to say,
but he had an a feminine accent.
I assumed he was gay. Not saying
he can't get married in someday.
Get divorced and lose half his shit.
He has the right to do that.
He has a right to do everything
straight people do. Even the dumb shit.
All right,
did I cover my tracks?
So he comes over and he goes,
hey man,
sorry about the blah blah.
He goes into a policy mode and I go
immediately into apology mode. I just say,
hey man, honest mistake. We thought he
was a taking a piss. I didn't know, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. And
then in the end when he walks
away, my other buddy goes,
no, I could hear him piston. So I
don't know what the fuck happened.
So then I guess the roof is
really fucking thin and you know,
they're playing music,
dancing and shit.
And then like the owner came up and then
a little bit later this security person
came up and I'm thinking the
whole fucking time these guys,
these Mexican dudes think that we called
those people that these white guys
showed up. Like, oh, what are
they doing up on our roof?
And that was completely not the case.
And I was sitting there and of course,
because I'm a Hollywood phony,
rather than actually giving
into the tension of it, I
was actually thinking like,
hey, this would be a really
good scene in a script.
Just a complete misunderstanding.
And uh,
I thought, I still think it's a comedy.
I don't think it's more like crash.
I think it's a comedy because they were
all young and in shape and we were a
bunch of old white guys smoking cigars.
So that would be a funny fight.
There would definitely be like,
you know the dual headlock shit going
on with the shirt coming up in the ass
crack coming out. You know what a real
fight looks like. It's never pretty,
you know, by the way, who all, who
saw the Mayweather fight? Anybody? Um,
I actually didn't see it. I heard it
was a, it was actually a good fight.
I just have so much faith in May,
whether as a,
as a fighter that I don't order his
fights because he just wins every fucking
time and, but he never knocks him out.
So I just watch him pepper in the guy,
you know, kind of dances around
the first couple of rounds. That,
is that what you're doing? Hey,
you can try and do that. Okay.
Did that pimp up a peep?
Ah, fuck it. Trey magic out again.
Fucking old guy starts yelling.
I don't know.
He made it more polo shirt. Your new
book gave a pip. I Dunno, I think.
Do you think he's going to get out
and he's got three more fights.
He's three more of, I'm actually
worried about me, whether I can't tell.
I know he's a smart guy,
but I can't tell if he understands
money or if that's all just to show,
you know what I mean?
Anytime you see a guy in a
field where age is a factor,
like by the time you hit
40 and they have like,
like fucking an airport
hangar of all white cars,
you know what I mean? You
just start saying that. Or
like once you buy the tiger,
what's some other dumb shit? You have
your own water park in your backyard.
I mean,
you just can't sustain that.
You literally start living
a lifestyle where it's like,
the only way I can afford this is this
for is if I'm champion of the boxing
world,
you know,
eventually you're going to be 50
and unless you Bernard Hopkins,
I mean you're not,
you're not going to be the champ anymore
and now you got a tiger next to a water
park next to fucking nine white
Bentley's and I don't know. I don't know.
You gotta get like that.
You got to get the,
you got to get the outside the
business money. You know what I mean?
I'm literally drawing a
half a circle right now.
As I'm saying outside the business money.
I'm trying to think of
a good example of it.
I would say 50 cent with this
fucking vitamin water. Brilliant.
Yeah,
that's fucking brilliant.
That's like a fucking hooker with who,
who fucking take so hookah money and then
fucking buys an apartment building so
you can get underneath out from underneath
your pimp because that's really kind
of what show businesses.
It's funny you come into this business,
you think you're the pimp, and then about,
I don't know, for me about 15 years in,
you're like, oh, wait a minute,
I'm the guy walking the block.
I need to somehow try and
make money outside of this
business because I can only
shake my ass for so long before another
young red heads going to be coming along
and then I'm finished. Right? So I
need, I need to go buy a whorehouse,
which is a fucking comedy club.
I don't know what I need to do,
but I got to start making money outside
of this business because I'll be fucked
if I'm going to be some old bald guy in
a fucking wrinkled Tuxedo on a cruise
cruise ship, you know,
I'll be sold at that point.
Not only will I be telling jokes,
I will,
I'll do be also kind of singing classic
songs from the American Song Book.
You know, you know what's
up with the president? Yeah.
We got to get back up budget. I think
you need to go back to fucking Arkansas.
People laugh and then I'd
be like, ah, here we go.
A Samoan but up k blow it in from across
the sea and I do a big thing like,
like,
like you know,
I got a fucking one of those check whores
on fucking prices, right? Oh, new car.
They do that little swing with their hand.
Like as if he can't see the fucking car.
That's what I would be doing a
cross the sea, you know, just like,
there it is.
We're out on a boat.
You are a fat fuck.
Okay.
You know, fucking dance with
me. We'll go to the casino.
You don't really like about cruise ships?
I don't like how they decide
when you fucking eat. You know,
like all of a sudden I
joined this guy's navy.
I did one cruise ship and that's
the thing that I hated the most.
Aside from the fact that you couldn't
get away from the crowd there. You good?
Sheller says ILS that, hey, just want to
tell you that. Take it to the fire house.
Fuck off. It's over. Hey,
I liked your shorts yesterday.
Those shorts, your war.
How would you like to hear that? I'll
fucking day. It's not their fault. I do.
You come up with your material.
I actually thought about jumping
overboard like half the fucking time,
and I am terrified of the ocean,
but I thought the water would be cold
enough that hypothermia would get me
before I get eaten by a fucking shark.
And even then by then I'd be so fucking
numb. You know? Maybe it wouldn't hurt.
Okay.
I don't know. What am I,
what was I talking about?
Oh, we're talking about race.
We're talking about racial issues.
Um,
so this week I'm going to try to remember
what the fuck happened. Oh, okay.
The first one that happened
literally happened the day
I put up the podcast. And,
um, you know, it's a fucking
pet peeve of mine is on Twitter.
Okay.
All right. When some con we'll
fucking send me a tweet. Male.
A female client. Okay. Equal,
equal look up, Tony. Um,
we'll say like, uh, hey bill,
did you see this thing about
Donald Sterling and the clippers?
And then they just write thoughts?
Yeah.
Like I'm just supposed to just
start fucking, oh, well shit.
Let me just take time out
of my fucking day, you know?
Hey, talk about, uh, this fucking thing
and then when you fucking talk about it,
I talked to you once a week on Monday.
Okay.
Fucking Twitter crunch. Drive
me nuts. Thoughts, thoughts.
Anyways, sorry, I'm really being a car
today, but I, I just, uh, I can't help it.
It's who I am. So anyways, yeah.
Uh, I love that. What, what,
what could your thought fucking
possibly be other than like, yeah,
that was horrific.
Yeah,
it'd beat. I'm like a lady. It's
not like I don't have a bit on it,
but I'm not going to do it on the podcast.
But a, I can't tell you this though.
I didn't understand what Mark Cuban was
talking about where they were saying,
well,
he gave these slippery slope.
Okay.
The slippery slope thing there.
There's always somebody like
whenever you like a, you know, hey,
this guy says he loves Hitler,
we got to get rid of them.
And then there's always that. Well, you
know, that's a slippery slope. You know,
you start with this guy, you know,
where do you draw the line? How about,
you know, you draw the line at a
racist with fucked up mustaches.
How about we draw?
It's pretty clear and present line.
Like I don't understand
where the slippery slope.
It's like if you're going to fire an
owner for being overtly racist, what next?
You don't like my shirt?
Ah, fuck. I mean I don't, I
actually, in defense of him,
I read the [inaudible]. Yeah, this isn't
the fence. They might just Google it.
And then I looked it up and I saw
these sense kind of retracted it. Um,
and all I have here is that the outspoken
billionaire said it was a slippery
slope to suggest that sterling should be
forced out as owner over comments made
in the privacy of his
home. Um, yeah, I mean,
well that's taken out of
context, but I, I don't know. He,
he said what said was wrong.
It was abhorrent.
I don't even know what that word means.
Must be bad cause whores in their hip.
Horan uh,
there's no place for racism in the NBA,
any business I'm associated with.
But at the same time,
that's a decision that I make.
I guess he's saying I make
a decision not to be racist.
I think you've got to be very,
very careful when you start making blanket
statements about what people say and
think as opposed to what they do.
It's a very,
very slippery slope. So what, what
is he saying there? I don't get it.
And is he saying that all right,
this guy says racist shit.
MMM.
In his personal life. But during
the day, his business is made,
he has 11 employees on his players,
on his team,
and 10 of them are African American.
So despite what he says on the fall,
if everybody hired the way this guy did,
I mean that's a higher than 90%
okay.
African met shit.
White people will be out of jobs.
I don't know what he's saying there.
I don't understand where the
slippery slope is, but um,
I dunno. Well, I mean, what,
what are you going to do with the
guy said when he fucking said,
and I understand that it was a private
conversation, but he was dumb enough
to do it over the phone. He,
he's just by dumb enough.
I'm not saying that you, he should have
just said it without being on the phone.
I'm, I know what he said
was wrong. But the thing is,
is every fucking move he made
is his own fucking fault.
That's his own fault.
Does his own fucking fault that you
would say something like that over the
fucking phone
to a woman who's acting like she's into
you, who's 50 years younger than you?
You're a fucking moron. It was
unbelievably reckless. And uh,
I'm glad he did it because a,
I dunno, it's just fucked up. It's
just fucking, you know, I don't, I,
I would,
I would understand that guy.
If that guy lived in the middle of
fucking nowhere and he lived around all
fucking white people and he was 80 years
old. I mean, that's a layup. I mean,
shit he does. Yeah. That's obviously
how he's got a fucking thing.
This guy was born in 1930 something,
you know,
and he was raised by people who were
born in like the turn of the fucking
century and had Harry Truman for a
president who was one of the most biggest
fucking racist sever. Right? Was that
his first fucking name? I don't know.
MMM.
So anyways, I mean, yeah.
What the fuck you think he's
going to be thought? I mean,
this guy, he got raised by racist and
then, and then he didn't fucking travel,
but this guy actually traveled.
Okay.
That's, that's the one that
I don't get. I don't get,
when you finally have interaction and
you actually have examples and it's a
specific person that you now know
that you can still think that way. Um,
and then the,
the fucking phone messages hilarious
because he's literally talking to somebody
who's half of,
what will she have a black half Latino
and he's literally trashing black people
tour. And as she's getting offended,
he's sitting there going like, oh,
you're mean, oh, don't you
understand how your words hurt
me
and is fucking awful as it was.
I would love to have that
level of money that you're,
that fucking just so wrapped
up in yourself that you
don't even realize you're
hurting people in your, actually you're,
you're playing the victim yourself.
I Dunno. So now it's actually, I don't
think he's going to try and sell the team,
which is going to be fascinating
as they try and force this guy out.
But I think they should be able to do
it because he's fucking with the whole
image of the league.
Okay.
You know, I dunno, one of it, one
of his shit like this comes out.
It always bugs me because then everybody
gets to act like holier than now
because they didn't get caught
saying anything fucked up.
You know what I mean? I don't know.
I think people say fucked up shit.
I think everybody says fucked up shit.
And I think people think fucked up shit
and they're just smart enough to not say
it out loud. And I don't even
think that it makes you a racist.
You just think you just see it.
You can't hit fucking help it.
Okay.
You just fucking, your
approach, how you grew up,
you proud of experience in every,
you know it is. Everybody has fear.
So fear will drive you into thinking
the worst of somebody if you're in a
fearful situation.
Like I used to do a bit in my act,
how everybody's racist at night and
almost like you have to be so you can get
home.
You have to think the worst of people.
So you're not that fucking idiot that
just walks into a wood chipper. Well yeah,
I'll help you start it,
go over there and get knocked
over the head and thrown in it.
And then that's the worst. Then the
next day everybody's like, yeah,
it's awful that it happened. But Jesus,
I think, well, what was this guy begging?
So, um, I don't know, but I've got
to commend all the clipper players.
We're actually still going
out and playing because, uh,
I don't know that I would have,
you know,
I mean, you've got to feel like
he just got to feel like, yeah,
I've worked for some club owners that
have been absolute dicks and I still had a
couple up a fucking shows left and I
wanted to like burn down the club and then
choke the guy to death and
throw them on the fucking ashes.
Like I've felt that and still had to
trudge through the show and there was no,
no racism involved.
There wasn't this negative thing that
affected my life every fucking day.
And then this guy
actually persona fight it.
It was just a guy being a dick and I
still had to go up there and entertain his
fucking,
the people that were coming there
because at that point it wasn't a draw.
So they will basically come to the
club and I wanted them to have a bad
experience because I wanted this
person to go out of business.
I can only relate to it at
that half a percent level.
So I can't imagine what the fuck they
will go through. But uh, it's going,
I have to tell you on a selfish level,
it's going to be really entertaining to
watch this guy fight the fucking NBA,
um,
and not try and
lose his team. I mean, Jesus
Christ. What a fucking situation.
It's just like, dude, just be a
fucking man now and just walk away.
You're going to drag down everybody
with you. One of those guys,
you know,
I dunno.
It's just what he did then
causes everybody else too.
A little bit about the other owners and
all of that type of shit. It's just,
he fucked up. He fucked up. He is fucked
up. He got caught a bunch of times.
I have a dental,
he doing other shit and he never changed
his fucking ways is fucking chickens
came home to roost and uh, you know,
and what's, what's his big penalty?
He sells it and has $1 billion,
you know,
let's go buy a yacht,
just drive out in the ocean and scream
all your racist shit. And you know,
you can be free out there, free
to do what you want. I don't know.
Did that make any fucking
sense? You don't. It was,
I had to fucking steer around all the,
all the funny areas where
I'm doing the bid on it. Oh.
And then also the,
uh,
the Boston Bruins in the Montreal command,
Canadian started another classic
classic playoff series a,
the first game went to
overtime fucking Canadians one.
And uh, then, uh,
they had game to looked like they had it
all wrapped up and the Bruins came back,
came storming back to steel
game too. So it's one, two, one,
two,
unbelievable.
Like I put those games up against any
fucking games and though in the history of
that series, but unfortunately, PK,
sue Vaughn scored the goal
in overtime in game one.
And then like a couple of
years ago when that other, uh,
African American player scored in
overtime goal on the capital's,
a portion of the Bruins fan base goes on
and starts fucking trending the n word
on a,
on Twitter and then,
and then that just opens the shit storm,
you know,
it's fucking ugly and all that
type of stuff and it really ruins,
it's such a pussy fucking move. You
know what I mean? It's such a fucking,
it's such a pussy fucking, I don't even
get it in 2014 to do something like that.
And a almost equally annoying is then
when people on Twitter start doing that
real classy Boston when they send out
like, that's like this hacky thing to say,
way to stay classy. Like who started
that and why does everybody say that now?
And you only use class when you're talking
about like a sports team now did that
come from Ron Burgundy stay classy.
San Diego? I don't know what it is,
but I don't understand why people on
Twitter can't express their views without
using like,
I dunno,
like Twitter language
white. Why can't you,
why can't you just say that? You know,
that was fucked up Boston whaler you know,
way to stay class or was that
like that trending thing?
I don't know what these
fucking kids are doing,
but here's the deal for all you holier
than thou cons that tried to make racism
a Boston thing. And I'm like, I
can't defend Boston. Norwell lie.
It isn't an overtly racist yet.
Liberal fucking bizarre place.
Like I think the reason why it's so
democratic is because so many people in
Boston want to get a fucking state job
so they don't have to work. I mean,
that was a lot of my friends.
I want to get on the doll,
I want to lean on a fucking
shovel and know, get the benefits.
Don't you know the fuck.
Um,
there's a lot of that go on that yet.
It's still just fucking overtly racist.
But having said that,
all you people that fucking wrote like
Boston was the worst fucking city ever.
Um, and also believe that racism
is in the south and in Boston.
Um, become a comedian and
traveled the road. And,
uh,
tell me what you think because
that has not been in my experience,
and I'm not gonna fucking be a Douche now
and name a bunch of towns or countries
that I've been to, but I got to tell
you that, uh, I dunno, it's weird.
It's on one level where I think we've
progressed a long way as far as maybe in
the media.
Okay.
Um,
it's not as bad and I,
but I sometimes I just think that people
just know what not to say now, but, uh,
on another level, I think a, you know,
yeah.
If the dollar collapsed, another Hitler
could come along and fucking crush it,
no problem there would,
there would be enough,
there would definitely be enough people
signing up for that at that point so
they could get their chicken noodle soup
and get a nice fucking outfit, you know,
and, and take out whoever the fuck
he supposed to take out. I basically,
that's what I have. I have, after
traveling all of that, I've traveled.
I have no faith in humanity.
Ah,
that's such a terrible thing to say, but
it's true. It's awful. It's fucking awful.
And you know what pks brother actually
plays for the minor league Bruins.
I don't know his name.
He plays goal. And uh,
so now this kid has to put on the fucking
Jersey of a fan base that not only
said it the most offensive
word to his race,
but called his brother that and it's
just fucking, I just wished, you know,
something.
I don't want like a big
brother or anything like that.
The only time I'm pro big brother is I
really wish that when you wrote shit like
that,
then all of a sudden,
like one of those police helicopters
would just be circling your fucking house.
And then you had to go
to work the next day,
hanging your head in shame because it's
such a pussy fucking thing to do. Uh,
and unfortunate and it
takes away from this,
this amazing series, the
Bruins verse, the Canadians,
which is going to go seven games.
And uh,
already there's a bunch
of great storylines going
on in it and the Canadians
have a great fucking team.
So the Bruins,
I feel like the Canadians on the way up
and we're getting a little bit old yet
we have this young defense.
I got tell you, dude,
I'm fucking loving Douggie Hamilton,
you know,
just because he's young. He shoots
the puck all the time, I feel,
and he's coming down offensively
and like, um, I dunno.
Whenever you get like an older defensemen,
it just seems they never shoot the
puck and they always do the smart play.
And you sit there like blowing out your
fucking voicebox screaming at the TV
going shut the fucking
day. Just showed it. I,
and I know they know the game
way more than me, but uh,
that doesn't stop me
from choked the fuck it.
They'd scream and you never have to
yell that it Doug Hamilton, it's great.
He just shoots it. Craig's the
same way. Fucking phenomenal,
by the way.
I absolutely loved Johnny Boychuk Boychuk
Johnny Boy Chuck Celebration when he
fucking blasted that one in from the, uh,
the Blue Line, the fucking Howard a shot.
And when he put his hands up in the air,
I swear to God he did his own
version of the frank the tank.
Remember frank the tank and old school
when he started fucking doing the thing,
like he was anti aircraft gun,
he did his a little slower.
So I think we hit as he was
doing more six shooters.
But that's gotta be the fucking
greatest feeling ever. And the NHL,
you're a Defenseman,
you could skate 90 miles an hour
backwards and then you bring it into the
offensive zone and you just,
from the Blue Line,
a fucking Bob goes right through
everybody right into the back of the net.
That's gotta be the greatest
fucking feeling ever. So
whatever. So the first one,
uh, the next game is going
to be in Montreal and
game three is always a fucking
crucial one in a seven game series.
MMM.
I think if the Bruins, when it, we're
definitely going to win the series.
I would say, well definitely
when the fucking series,
if we lose that game, it's,
it's going to be an uphill battle.
I still think we can do it just because
we have enough guys who were experienced.
Um,
but I dunno,
that game's reason that
motherfucker, uh, Allen, by the way,
look at the Black Hawks.
All right.
They
now they're where they want six in a row.
Those mother fuckers are
going to win it all again.
And I think that we can get to the finals
and I'm worried that it's going to be
the same problem that we ran into last
year, which was they were just too deep.
They just had too many fucking
guys. You know, Patrick Kane,
Hosa,
Jonathan Tabes and then you got there,
great defense know Duncan [inaudible]
halls guys. And it's just,
it's just too fucking,
you know,
like you just don't get time off man.
It's a fucking,
they are still is still the team to
beat. And I think that they can, uh,
I mean they went and again this year,
that's 2010,
2000.
No wait,
there was a 2010 then we
wanted an 11 who won 2012.
They want it last year,
obviously. Oh, the kinks. Also,
that wouldn't be a dynasty because
they would want three and five years.
They'll give you three out of four.
They'll call it a dynasty.
Back in the day you had to went three
years in a row to be at dynasty. Um,
okay.
But either way, three and five
years would be the shit. So I,
I mean my money's on them to win
it all. I just don't see, um,
yeah.
You know, barring injury, I just don't see
anybody stopping him. I hate to say it.
I mean,
I'm obviously my heart.
My brain tells me that my heart for the
Bruins out, but uh, it's been amazing.
And um, I've been kind of watching
a little bit. The NBA playoffs,
they look like they're fucking great too,
but I just,
I just don't watch this shit.
You gotta pick one of the other dude,
I got to tell you right now,
if you're watching all the
NHL in all the NBA playoffs,
you have no fucking life. There's
no, especially the first round.
Okay.
Jesus Christ,
you're going to fucking watch 16 playoff
series or whatever the hell it is.
He left. There's no way you can do it.
Hey Bill, we're not arguing with you.
Fucking relax. Okay. Um, all
right, here we go. Let's, uh,
let's read a little bit of advertising
here. How far into this thing? Oh,
we feel given runoff cheeses fucking
half hour already. All right. All right.
Sherry's berries, everybody.
Here's the theme. Treat.
Mom does some Sherry's berries are
good friends at Sherry's berries.
They're back.
Ordered a giant,
freshly dipped strawberries from
Sherry's berries starting at 1999.
Over a 40% savings or double
the berries for just $10 more.
Go to Barry's dot com.
Click on the mic in the upper right
hand corner and enter my code burpee.
You are when you order.
I got to tell you,
a bunch of people have ordered these
off of my podcast because of my, uh,
my silly reads. And there's not one
person who hasn't said that they're not.
Fuck it. Absolutely delicious. So
there you go. I'm going to continue.
After all your mom kept you
alive and fed you for years.
Go to Barry's dot com and get your mom
freshly dipped berries for 1999 when you
went to my code bur bur make your
mom proud with this sweetness.
Enormous, fresh, juicy, mouthwatering.
Barry's white milk and dark
chocolate covered goodness.
Top with chocolate chips,
decorative swizzle or nuts or do your
mom's some Sherry's berries today.
Go to berries.com and enter code bur
bur and show your brothers and sisters.
Why your mom's favorite child.
This deal expires Friday at midnight,
so make sure you order now.
All right? Okay. Flowers.
Mother's Day is this week.
Here you go is the ying and the Yang.
I you can get us some
chocolate strawberries and I
can get her some flowers and
your mom's going to love your
mother's Day is this week.
It's on May 11th that's Sunday.
Everybody,
your mom did carry you around for nine
months and dealt with all your mess until
you left her house. Give the woman
some flowers for God's sakes.
Order of beautiful hundred blooms, bouquet
or bowl, k over the hell you say it.
Plus a free glass vase from
file proflowers.com for
just 1999 upgrade to 100
blooms with a pink vase and chocolates
for just nine 99 more for your listeners
can get this special mother's Day offer
using your code bur bur pro flowers are
guaranteed to last a full week
or you get your money back.
The only way to get this amazing mother's
Day deal is to go to proflowers.com
click on the blue mic,
uh,
at the top of the right hand corner
and typing [inaudible], B u, R, r,
that's pro flowers.com.
Click the blue Mike and type and bur
bur this deal also expires Friday at
midnight. Make sure you order today.
You, you kid, you got it easy.
Back in the day we had to
go out and go buy flowers.
We had to go and go pick some
chocolates out. Now what do you do?
You just sit there and you just make a
couple of clicks and it's all done and
get on with your life. You can get
on to getting shit faced tonight.
Celebrating Cinco de Mayo. I
told you years ago, I asked, uh,
what date is Cinco de Mayo and
for other people as white as me,
Cinco de Mayo literally means
the 5th of May. Oh Geez.
All right. He voice.
You're a business owner,
but automated phone systems
and secretaries are not
in your budget just yet.
And juggling incoming calls
yourself makes it very,
makes it very hard to look like a
professional who's couldn't help.
Here's something that will dramatically
help you make more money in 2014.
What is it? It's a voice. Everybody, uh,
whether you're a business of one or 100,
he voice will help you manage all of your
incoming calls with a toll free number.
Dial by name,
directory and call routing tools.
Your business will sound like 1 million
bucks. Can't take a call, no problem.
He voice. We'll transcribe the
voicemail and email it to you.
Never be caught off guard again.
And with the voice you can try
it before you buy it right now.
Just for my listeners,
you can get a free 60 day trial.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter
Promo Code Bill B I l l at checkout.
Take charge of your business and make
more money in 2014 go to [inaudible] dot
com and enter bill at checkout
for your 60 day free trial.
That's [inaudible] dot
com Promo Code Bill.
Um, uh, all right,
I'll read the last three a little bit
later. Okay, now let's continue on.
Um, I did something very
UN redhead ish yesterday.
I actually went to the beach.
I'm not because I want it to,
my wife wanted to go and, uh, I gotta
tell you I don't like the beach.
All right? It's fucking dirty and
it's too hot. I'm not built for it.
You know, people just stare
at me like, look at it.
Is it gonna take his shirt off?
Or at least they feel like they are.
You know, I go out there and
it's just, it's a shit show.
It's a fucking shit show.
But, uh, I love my wife,
so I took it and she has a
great time soaking up the sun.
She absolutely loves it. And it's just
one of those things I have to deal with.
You know,
it was funny,
we ran up a mall cause I had to buy some
sunglasses cause this fucking dickhead
bus boy stole my sunglasses.
I get this nice pair of sunglasses.
I did this acting Gig, right?
And in the end they got
everybody something got really
a nice pair of sunglasses
that actually looked really good
on my fat fucking head. And uh,
I went into a Vegan restaurant,
everybody Vegan fucking restaurant,
my favorite Vegan restaurant in Los
Angeles. Could I sound more pretentious?
I'm bitching about sunglasses
that I got for free,
for working in acting in a movie and now
going to a Vegan restaurant and now I'm
going to bitch because the bus
boys stolen and yeah. Yeah.
That's how out of touch I am.
You know what? Fuck that dude.
I was a busboy and I didn't steal shit.
I fucking send them down.
I walked out and I,
the time it took me to walk to my car
I said I'll fuck, can I turn back?
And my table was clear and
they had already sat down
to other fucking emaciated
fucks, you know, to eat some brown
rice and beans. And uh, I go,
I left my sunglasses and
there can be camphor. Hey,
I got the busboy cleared off the table,
ask him. And he's just like, Yay.
He say he didn't see him and then
I was just like, yeah. Oh really?
So I'm not going to get him back.
Basically basically saying that he fucking
swiped them. And then she's just like,
no. Like they, people have found
I iPads and they did. Yeah.
Cause it's fucking big to fucking iPad.
Ah.
[inaudible] me off.
You know something.
I don't mind losing a pair of
sunglasses in a steak house.
You don't to use stereotypes.
You expect somebody do that.
Been a fucking Vegan restaurant.
Is it supposed to be all like,
hey man, like, no, I'm a stay, you know,
happy Tuesday,
man.
This is the only Tuesday and [inaudible]
right. That's supposed to be that vibe.
Okay.
I just kept picturing some Douche out at
a party wearing those fucking glasses,
you know?
And I had all these fucking Jason State
them fantasies of how I action hero my
way in to get my fucking sunglasses back.
Except I have such a temper.
Even in my fucking fantasies.
I still punched him in the face,
threw my glasses and broke them.
Huh?
You want them there is do they
are stuck in your fucking head.
Not a piss me off. So anyway, so uh,
so we go out to the beach and we're out.
This is mall in Malibu,
right? And it's just like the trophy
wife fucking, it's, it's unreal.
It's unreal. Like they are
walking around in trophy wife,
he know a trophy wife because she's,
you know,
she's still trying to look hot like
well into a fifties she has kids.
It's like you did it, you're
married. Yeah, you have kids.
Why are you still trying to look fuckable
just look like a mom. It's great.
Comfortable clothes given to it. But
the thing is, is they don't have,
they don't have like a, I think that they
know that the second they let it slide,
you know that, that they're going
to get traded in or something.
I don't know what it is. They
all looked least to me, you know.
So anyway, so I went over there and
bought a pair of [inaudible] sunglasses.
Then it went to the god Damn Beach, kept
my tee shirt on the whole fucking time.
I just sat there putting on sunblock
50. Oh yeah. I also said, you know,
should we get an umbrella?
You want to get an umbrella?
So like he can like sit in the shade.
And I was like, no, I don't want it to,
cause I don't want to see me
even like more of a freak. Um,
and then when I got there,
there was a bunch of people with fucking
umbrellas who actually had pigment and
then I felt like an asshole and a
okay.
I Dunno.
I ended up just walking down along the
water and the water was fucking ice cold.
And, uh, even when I get like knee deep
in the ocean, I just think like, you know,
what are these a fucking shark and just
swims by and sees my white calf and it
looks like a fucking drum stick. Like
why would you go in this God damn thing?
I, I literally don't
fucking understand it on it.
Like I guess I do because
people surf every day,
like the amount of people that surf the
whole life and they never get bit by a
shark. But this is the
funny thing. They, uh,
there's not a surfer I've
ever met that hasn't seen one.
I talked to someone in Hawaii, right.
And they will go on like a, I go, dude,
don't nervous about sharks. They're
like, well, I mean, you know,
you try not to think about it.
And I go, have you ever seen one?
And she was just like,
well yeah,
I just kind of lie to myself and say it's
a porpoise that maybe it's a porpoise.
Like do you just see something big swim
underneath you and you just fucking
don't look at it?
Look the way you don't look at as psycho
on a subway train or whatever. I Dunno.
I, I really, I honestly do not
have the fucking balls for that.
So, um, anyways, oh, guess
what I rented this week.
I rented a Chevy spark. Um, um,
we're finally getting the downstairs fixed
after all the water damage, you know,
cause this fucking house
is the money pit and a,
so we're getting that shit fixed
downstairs. So I have my car,
my truck in the garage, and they got to
bring all the shit in through the garage.
So I to,
you know,
I didn't wanna leave my truck out on
the street because I was afraid it was
going to get stolen.
So I had to put that in fucking storage.
Okay.
And Nias working and shit. So now I
had to go rent a car. So they said,
what do you want us to let me get a
mid sized car, whatever, fucking sedan.
Perfect. So I show up down
there and they did the crisis,
like griswell moved to me where they
bring out the family truckster and they
basically like,
well you're the Camry or whatever the
fuck is still being washed or Corolla is
what it was.
Okay,
but this one's already
ready and I was late.
I had to get the fuck out of there.
Okay.
I already hated being there,
so I say, fuck it. I'll take
that little fucking car,
dude. It is the worst hunk
of shit. You know, I don't,
I don't get mad at cars
for being what they are.
If you're a little car and
you're a great little car,
I actually fucking love him. Like I like,
you know, VW bugs in that type of shit.
But this thing is so fucking underpowered
just with one person in the car,
if I put the AC on, it is literally
screaming at like, I swear to God,
like 4,000 rpms going up
like the littlest inclined.
But I got to tell you, having watched
every episode of Fast and loud,
that would be a fucking hilarious
car to Redo a Chevy spark.
If you somehow yanked that engine
out and you could turbocharge a,
maybe you could get a six in there and
just put a fucking hurst shifter in there.
I bet you could tip
that fucking thing over
and there would no,
no way would that car not be one of
the most fun cars you would ever drive
because it would be like driving this
fucking this turbo charge golf cart.
That's all I keep thinking about that.
Can I just keep thinking of
the potential of that thing?
And that is the fucking
disease of watching.
And the great thing about watching those
car shows is rather than just accepting
your car for what it is, you start
getting fucking ideas. Like, oh,
what if I did this?
What if I did that? Um,
that's why I wanted somebody to paint
my file cabinet, which by the way,
I never even gave into,
I finally just looked at it and I just
hated the file cabinets so bad. I just,
I gave it away to somebody.
So it was a complete fucking loss.
So when are you guys who've been asking
me for pictures about my custom painted
file cabinet? I ended up just
giving it away and I felt great.
I felt like a weight
was taken off my chest.
It was just something about it that was
just so fucking depressing to look at.
Um,
I don't want to fucking file cabinet.
That's one of the worst sounds ever.
The opening and closing
of a fucking file cabinet.
Okay.
Have you ever heard that sound
and Ben where you wanted to be?
You know,
it's just an awful sub.
I remember that sound when
I got my license back from
drinking and driving when
he opened it and fucking closed it and
he as he was handing me the fucking
license back this statey
right as I went to grab it,
he pulled it back away and he goes,
wait, what was it for 45 days if for 90?
And just gave me that last
little fucking heart attack. Um,
just to be a dick in a good way
to teach me a fucking lesson. Um,
okay.
I, speaking of that, somebody told me
you went on a Twitter to watch this
thing on, uh, on Netflix, on green berets.
I don't even know if I rented the
right one. There's a couple of them.
The one that I rented was, uh, I dunno,
some 11 weeks of hell or
something to hang on a second.
Let me see if I can find this shit.
Oh, sorry. 11 weeks. Two weeks.
Do you know what I said? 11 because of
the two L's and health. I swear to God,
the way my brain works, this is the
only fucking job I could ever do.
So this is a couple of,
there's one national Gri of geographic
special forces brought over this two
weeks in hell.
I was watching this thing they just
showed the first couple of fucking days.
I can tell you right now,
there's no fucking way I
could ever be a green baret.
You lie to yourself having never been
in the military that I could do that.
You know,
I put my fucking head down no fucking way.
Yes.
Go on Netflix and check that out.
That's my youtube video of the week,
except it's on Netflix.
Watch two weeks of hell.
I've only watched the first episode.
Okay
Dude, it's just fucking insane.
The first day you're there,
they have a thousand pound
log that 12 guys grab.
Yeah.
And you're just sitting there bending
over at the waist as you're holding it.
Like you're going to do curls.
Yeah.
Up, down, up, down, up, down,
up, down. Like my lower back
would just, that would be hit.
I would never walk right again.
And then they have it on your shoulder
and you got to pick it up over your head
and then down and then,
and they're sitting there going,
move the lug around your head,
not your head around the law,
number one 67,
what is your problem? They
fucking going off on him. And uh,
you do that for like a fucking hour.
Then they just have you rolling on the
ground from one side of the pit to the
other.
And if you too slow,
other people roll over you
and it's supposed to make
you dizzy and disoriented.
And when you puke,
you have to get up and run out of the pit.
There's no puking in the pit,
but they know you're going to Puke,
so you have to run out of the pit
and Puke. If you puke in the pit,
you have to pick the puke up and put it
in your pockets and then get back on the
ground to start rolling again.
And
even the people who are
dropping like flies,
I got to commend them for even
less than an hour of that shit.
You got to see it all right.
If you think you're working out
doing your insanity workout,
go fuck yourself and watch this thing.
It's the sick I and,
and now I'm just on the second episode
with it, just showing the teamwork.
Oh my God. Do they have one thing? They,
they're new mill in North Carolina and
they call this thing like the star where
you have these five points to make a star
that you have to find using navigation
and you can't use your light and you
can't go on the roads and you're just
walking through the fucking forest.
And when come upon a river or a pond, you
have to walk through the fucking thing.
You can't go on a road and they bused all,
you can't sleep.
They bus and they got these guys with
these infrared goggles like Rambo hiding
and catching all of these guys when
they cheat and then you're out of the
fucking program. Um, it's just like,
I don't think I could go more than 18
seconds watching this thing without going.
I'd quit there. I'd quit
there. I would fail that.
The only thing I thought I'd
be halfway decent on is the a,
the obstacle course because, uh,
I do pull ups and climb a rope,
but even then I do pull ups and
climb a rope after eight hours sleep.
And I had a nice bowl of oatmeal,
you know,
my wife gives me a kiss on the cheek and
then I go down there and I do is I go
and, you know, I do as many as
I can until it starts to hurt.
That hurts.
And then I stopped.
Ah, Jesus. I thought I was way closer to
being in Greenbrae than I actually am.
I thought I was only, you know,
1 million miles away from it.
I didn't realize I was light years
away. So, uh, anybody listen to this,
if you ever even attempted to become one
if or if you are one or whatever you,
if you have any fucking personal stories
that you could send in about attempting
that, uh, I don't know. The
level of pain, whatever,
what it's like to scoop up.
You can put it in the fucking pockets.
I Made Jesus Christ.
You know what's funny is those, you know,
when you join a Frat, how they go, Hey,
they have hell week and
all that type of shit.
Like anybody's a Greenbrae should be
an honorary member member of every
fraternity in the country because
I know that those fucking what it,
why can't I remember how long it is? I
want to say two weeks. It is two weeks.
I keep thinking 11 they're
right there, dude, look at that.
I have already fucked in the head before
they actually deprived me of sleep.
They asked this one guy, they go, how
long have you been in here? And he said,
Hash browns.
Okay.
And this is the thing,
he didn't take a head shot.
It's not like a football player.
They just had him pick a
log up for a fucking hour,
enroll around in the ground.
And they asked him,
they asked him something like that,
like how you feeling? And he said,
hashbrowns so I dunno Jesus Christ,
if that doesn't make you want to watch it,
I don't know what we'll all right,
let's get on to the, um, the
questions for the week. Uh,
all right. Uh, no bends in
Israel. Oh, Jesus. Did I make
an ass of myself last week?
Somebody sent me a letter last
week. MMM. And the guy said,
hi, my name is Ben and I'm
from Israel. And I said, dude,
there's no fucking Ben's in Israel.
Like I thought that was
more of an American name.
And I've met a bunch of people from
Israel and they always have these crazy
fucking names. Most of them
begin with a y, you know,
you know,
like these bad ass,
like I know Israeli martial arts
Moussad kind of fucking names, right?
I never heard a Ben,
Hey, my name's skippy.
They just sound like a regular
fucking name to me. So anyways,
and I got corrected brutally in
this fucking email here. Bill,
you said on your four 28 14 podcasts that
no one from Israel is named Ben Dude,
they're prime minister is
named Benjamin Netanyahu.
Their fucking president
basically is named Benjamin.
Well I probably didn't hear it cause
they always say his whole name Benjamin
Netanyahu.
You know like you have think how many
sports guys have really fucking awful
names, but you never noticed it
until they just say their first name.
But if you hear though the whole name,
I can't think of a name,
but there's a couple of people that
just have really fucking awful God damn
names. Let me think. I don't know.
I'll, I'll, I'll think of one.
I won't think of one.
I'll walk around and all of a
sudden it'll just pop in my head.
Maybe I'll bring it up next
week, but yeah. All right.
She got me number two solid info bill,
except Ben is an name of Hebrew origin.
It means son of the south
or son of the right hand.
Hold yourself a press conference.
I don't know what that means.
Um, all I know is that it's
an unbelievably arrogant
name to name your kid,
son of the right hand. I'm
assuming of God, Jesus Christ.
Where to give the kid a complex.
The second he comes out of the womb,
he's got to live up to that name. Why
don't you go native American? You know,
like he who sits with the hawks,
you know you got to do is hang out with
some fucking birds and your dad loves
you. Um, number three.
How about Ben Stiller?
Your blockhead.
What about them?
I'm going to Google them right now.
Why you acting like that guy's from?
Is he from Israel? Now Jesus am
I make it another fucking moron.
I thought he from New York.
Ben Stiller born in Brooklyn.
The fuck. I mean, I know. I'm
German and Irish. My name is,
and Wolfgang, you know
I have, I have bill.
I guess that's probably an English
name. I had a fucking, now you know, go.
You know something. This is what I
don't like about this shit is listen,
look at the way this dude calls
me out. He can't just say, hey,
you made a fucking honest
mistake. Right? He goes, Bill,
I know you're going to get a ton of
me emails about this Ben thing because
you're wrong is fuck
great debating skills.
Do you have a counterargument? Yeah,
this guy's wrong is fuck. Uh, anyways,
he goes,
Bill.
But I know you're going to admit you're
wrong because that's what you do best.
You're always ready to admit when you're
wrong and that my friend means you're a
trustworthy person. Oh, look at them now.
Now that he fucking called me a moron
areas, he's bringing me back into this,
this fucking a sadistic relationship.
I'm sorry baby.
I shouldn't have said those
things about you. Come on, let me,
let me go buy a burger. Um, anyways,
he says a true sign of honesty. Uh,
no sir.
It isn't it,
it just because somebody who's honest
on a podcast doesn't mean they fucking
walk around doing trust. I'll a complete
piece of shit, but I appreciate it. Um,
anyways,
read this email after the
others and realize I could
be a great publicist if you
need one, I'll be the Benicio
del Toro to your Johnny Depp.
Like in fear and loathing.
I'll be a bit of a mess.
You know some drugs and I don't know
where this guy's going with this shit.
I'm all right.
Probiotics.
Thank you for letting me
know Sir Benjamin Netanyahu.
I never noticed his first name was Ben.
This just so many syllables in letters,
like that's a name.
Like you know when somebody drives by
in a car and they try to yell some ad?
Yeah, you just hear, yeah,
that's like what that guy's
name is Benjamin Netanyahu.
How the fuck am I supposed
to even notice Ben?
After you get to Jamon Netanyahu,
it's fucking God.
Like The Ben part.
It's like being part of a part of a large
family trying to get your story and at
the dinner table I was getting
who I fucked up. All right, bye.
I have to be honest with you. Like, I,
I forget Obama's first name a lot of the
times because I don't pay attention to
politics. And, uh, it's
always like Obamacare. Oh,
you know that boy who's just,
what'd you give the vogue? Vrbo,
are you surprised or Barb a lot? And they
just keep saying Obama. Obama, Obama,
nobody ever says is first fucking name.
Okay.
I guess. Say we say
Clinton, they said Bush.
I Dunno.
Okay.
I just sit there and think what
the fuck is this guy's first name?
That's how out of it I am. So if I don't
even know my presence first name, Barack,
or I've got to think about it.
Yeah.
Out of fuck,
am I going to know Benjamin Netanyahu?
Okay.
I can't stand looking at that part
of the fucking world. Anyways,
that's such a shit show over there.
And the way that whole thing
was fucking handled to right.
A wrong with another wrong. And then
the wrong becomes the, the, the, the,
the so called right.
Become the wrong.
It's just the whole fucking
thing is absolutely ridiculous.
They should just take everybody out
of there. Palestinians and Jews.
And he just fucking,
I dunno,
push the whole thing into the ocean
and just why don't you guys go,
go live in a place where you
just just look at it like, oh,
I like this street.
You know,
rather than tying all that stupid fucking
religious horse shit into that part of
the world. Well, this is where
God, Jesus use the Porta potty.
Eddie said, I love everybody,
but I love you guys best,
but whatever the fuck it is,
everybody's the chosen one.
You Punch your fucking babies.
That's the dumbest shit ever.
Yeah, I'll probably get a bunch of emails
on that, but I, I really feel that, like,
I swear to God, if I was part of either
one of those groups, I would just be like,
oh, you know what? I'm fucking,
I'm going to move to Rhode Island.
I'm going to get the fuck outta here. Fuck
this. You want it? It's yours. Go ahead.
It gives a fuck.
Sit.
They're dealing with is Hatfield and
McCoys shift for the rest of my God damn
life. I want to go, I want
to go ride a boogie board.
I want to take a cooking class. I don't
want to fucking deal with this shit,
you know,
I don't know.
It's like I got burned out in
that Yankees red sox should after.
Well the while he just like you.
Yeah. And I did reduce it to that.
It's fucking childish.
There you go.
The guy who didn't know that Benjamin
was in Israelis name is telling that
entire part of the world to grow
up after the fan base of the team.
He loves drop the n word this
week. How's that? You like that?
How's that for you guys at a nice
big bullet? Hypocrisy for you?
Well, get used to it. Um, oh by the way,
last night I came home and I
was an absolute fucking saint.
My wife was sitting down and she was
watching that guy there, um, who,
who basically he has all
the real housewives get on
the show and then he just
stokes the flames to get them arguing.
And it was the Nini leaks group of people.
And I sat there and didn't say a fucking
word and it might have been some of the
meanest, most horrific shit. Um,
I, I've ever heard people say to each
other and they all just look tired.
They just look spent there.
These ugly fucking looks on their faces
and they would just say in all of this
hurtful shit to each other, and I
didn't say a fucking word. I usually go,
how can you watch this shit?
You know,
I thought you were a feminist.
How can you watch this shit?
This is like depicting women.
Like they can't even get
along for five seconds and a,
I didn't say shit last night and actually
Nia came in afterwards and was like,
I had to shut that off.
I actually
had physical reactions trying to watch it.
The,
some of the meanest shit I've ever
heard anybody say to each other.
And I think I'm done with that show.
So there's one for the guys out there,
just stop complaint,
just sit there in silence.
If you just sit there in silence
and let those women's voices,
you know, why should he say those
women? Just say those people,
cause I'm not trying to
make it a female thing. I,
one of them said to the other
one, I mean dude, it was like,
it was be on a roast,
it would've got grown.
This woman's trying to get
pregnant using a sperm donor.
Yeah.
And this woman was saying like, you have
to do that because you don't have a man.
So now some guy who wants $10 to go buy
a pizza is now going to go jerk off into
a cup and you don't know if you're
going to have a serial killer or a child
molester for a baby because
you don't have a man.
And then she said something Sassy after
that. Like, uh, you know, I dunno,
I dunno, I'm not up on SAS, you know,
put that in your checkbook and fucking
cash it in or whatever the fuck,
what the fuck she said. But
it was, it was just like,
and you just saw the fucking
hurt on the other woman's face.
Like she almost,
and then another woman who also
doesn't like that woman like laughed.
It was fucking,
it was fucking
brutal. I mean, I mean, look,
fucking comedians that I've hung
out with from Patrice O'Neal,
rest his soul to Keith Robinson,
those two alone and rich vos like some
of this shit that they said like this,
like paled in comparison.
Jesus fucking Christ. It was brutal,
but I didn't say a fucking word.
I Dunno. I was in the zone.
I didn't say anything.
I just sat there and I was looking at
a drum magazine and it was occasionally
look up and I didn't say a fucking word.
And then finally
everything that I wanted her to
think about the show finally happen,
I think because I finally shut the fuck
up and she could actually listen to it.
Or maybe they truly just went way too far.
Um,
she said she was done with that show.
So now I have this hope that if I just
shut the fuck up during all of these
reality shows where it's
a bunch of fucking people,
men and women just yelling at each other,
that she'll finally stop watching
them and then start watching sports.
I know that's not going to happen,
but I can, I can fucking dream. Right?
I can have a dream.
All right.
You know what my dream is right now is
to read these next three ads without
making too many fucking mistakes. Okay?
All right. Dollar Shave club, everybody.
Nothing feels better than that first
shave with a fresh blade, right?
It's smooth. It's close in. The blade
is as sharp as it's ever going to be.
It feels absolutely fantastic,
but thanks to the big shaving
company is ridiculous prices.
You can't afford it to use a fresh blade
every week or even if you can. The, the,
the sheer principle of having to overpay
for that little piece of crap that
they're acting like is a bar of gold.
So what do you do?
You drag that Dell as blade across your
fakes face for two weeks, three weeks,
10 weeks.
Why do you do that to yourself?
Maybe because the only thing more
painful than shaving with an old blade is
shelling out 30 bucks
for a pack of new ones.
If you want to enjoy a
fresh blade every week,
but you don't want take out a
second mortgage on your house,
you got to join dollar
Shave club.com Jode uh,
for just a couple bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com ships me the
highest quality blades you can get.
I'm a four blade guy.
That's not true.
I like the three or the two if they
still made it. But I'll take the three.
And with dollar shave club, it's only
six bucks for a four pack. Seriously,
only six bucks for the best
quality blades you can get.
So every week I can pop in a fresh blade
and treat myself to a Ma to an amazing
shave and it's great for your skin.
Joined Dollar Shave club.com get amazing
quality blades in the mail for a couple
bucks and treat yourself to
a brand new blade every week.
Hundreds of thousands of guys
with, um, now that's a typo.
with have upgraded their shaving.
I think we don't need the with hundreds
of thousands of guys have upgraded their
shaving with dollar shave club.com and
I am one of them and I'm loving it.
So now it's your term shave time. Shave
money with dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/pir
and enjoy a nice smooth shave today.
All right, legal zoom.com and you
know I'm actually on the side here.
I cause I looked up Ben Stiller.
He's actually getting much better
looking with age, you know,
unless these are just bad pictures of
him when he was younger and Jesus do I
have a crush on him? Old Ages
I legal zoom, legal zoom,
legal, zoom, everybody. Modern
technology is great. Matt phones,
iPads and other gadgets make
it easy to do so many things.
But why is it that our lives
seem busier at the same time?
Cause you have to download the new system.
Is that what it is? I Dunno anyways.
Well when it comes to getting
the legal help you need,
legal zoom provides a great solution
that works with your busy schedule.
Let's face it,
the legal system is complicated.
There are better things
you can do with your time.
Thankfully legal zoom is there for you.
So if you're thinking about setting, uh,
starting a business, forming an LLC or
getting a trademark will or living trust,
legal zoom gets the job done right,
you'll get the personal attention you
need and they'll help you take care of the
details on.
They'll help you take care of the details.
Legal Zoom has been helping
families and small businesses,
small business owners for 14 years and
they received an a plus from the better
business bureau. Call or visit legal
zoom today for an extra discount.
Enter bur bur are in the
referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com discount
code bur bur are legal.
Zoom provides legal help
through independent attorneys
and self help services,
but it is not a law firm.
Go to legal zoom.com enter in the disk,
enter the discount code
bur bur and lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com everyone making
trips to the post office is becoming
a thing of the past.
You just don't need to do it anymore.
Thanks to stamps.com you're already
know that going to the post office is
inconvenient. Driving there,
finding parking, waiting
in line, Yada, Yada, Yada,
but you probably didn't know
you're paying more for postage.
Then you have to stamps.com is the better
way by in print official US postage
for any letter, any package right
from your computer and your printer.
Then just hand it to the mailman with
stamps.com you'll get special postage,
special postage discounts.
You can't get at the post office on
FirstClass priority mail international and
more. Never go to the post office
again right now. Used by last name.
BURP bur for the special offer.
No risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer.
It includes a digital scale and up
to $55 free postage. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
[inaudible] Bam. There you go. All right.
Okay.
It's gets in the next, uh, the next
email, the week probiotics one.
This guy got it. He's got it all
broken down here. Number one. Hey Bill,
just to let you know, you don't have to
take yogurt to get your probiotics in.
You can just take
acidophilus as a dolphin list.
I Dunno.
It's a pill that has billions of cultures
of probiotics. It's really fantastic.
I take it all the time.
Um, what's the side effect?
That's what I want to know. I always get
nervous with taking pills. Like they're,
you know,
they're doing great for my gut,
but they're kicking the shit out of my
liver. All right. Just for the fun of it.
Let's look, let's look at, let's do
a little conspiracy research here.
All right.
A acid.
Yeah.
Come on bill. You can do it. The word is
right in front of you as sid. Oh, Phyllis.
Side effects.
Let's see what comes up.
Okay.
Doo Doo, Doo Doo, Doo,
Doo, Doo, Doo. You know,
Merv Griffin gets paid every time they
play that fucking song or his dead body
does. Um, this part, it contains
the bacteria [inaudible],
which is actually fine in the stomach
due to to some conditions such as an
antibiotic use can cause problems with
the normal balance of bacteria resulting
in diarrhea. This product can
help restore the normal balance.
Park has been used for vaginal
urinary track infections.
Some diet supplement products
have been forced to contain.
Wait a minute,
some diet supplement products have
been forced to contain possibly harmful
impurities.
Additives,
check with your pharmacist
for more details regarding
the particular brand use.
Also,
it's pretty much straight up.
You just gotta make sure
you don't get a bad one.
The FDA has not reviewed this
product for safety or effectiveness.
Consults your pharmacist for more
details. Well, there you go sir. Wait,
when was this written?
May 5th, 2014. Now this is the thing,
is this some other company just putting
this out because they have another pill
so that they're just writing bad shit.
Like the people who made Jeep said this
is Suki Samurai tipped over when it
didn't cause they wanted to
sell more jeeps. Who, how
do you know who to believe?
I'm at medicine.net.
That's pretty fucking,
I dunno. I Dunno. It just seems,
does that seem like that's
okay
Dr Com? I don't know. It sounds kind
of fucking generic. I Dunno. Whatever.
I so he's saying is fantastic.
What do I know? What does he know?
What does anybody know?
I don't know.
I'm going to keep fucking reading
number two, uh, Kefir or Kefir.
K E F I r is like normal yogurt but has
many more strains of good bacteria in it.
Like those pills you were looking at.
I drink it in the morning,
in the morning to respect my stomach.
After a night of boozing.
It's at all the grocery stores.
All right, well fuck it.
I'll try that. See how I feel.
Um, thank you for the information.
I'm somebody who else was saying that
that Stonybrook yogurt is a all natural
Stonyfield Stonyfield yogurt. I just
got to find out where to get it. Um,
cause I'm trying to get in shape for
my, uh, my damn special coming up. Uh,
also by the way, tickets going
on sale for my special, uh,
we'll be in the next week.
I'll have more information.
Okay.
MMM. Sorry. I have an Asian band.
Isn't a select agent karate movie
to first learn the way you must walk away.
Okay.
Um, I ride, I get it. Don't you know I'm
not going to fucking pick it up after this
fucking 15 rings. All right. Thanks for no
music. That's funny. Thanks for no music.
And then there was some music right
there. Thanks for no music, Billy. Boy,
I'm so fucking glad that your
podcast doesn't start with music.
Now that I said that the next one
probably will. I don't enjoy it.
When podcasts tried to go pro
and slick it all up to look real,
a rigid fuck that just shut
up and talk. I say, all right,
well I'm not doing that because
I'm trying to be a purist.
I got into this business because
I didn't want to have a job,
so I don't edit these. I just sit
down. I talk for the most part.
I don't have guests, although
I did a special one. Uh,
last week I did an extra
one with the head director,
Steven Brill of the movie walk of
shame that I have a [inaudible]
now that you have passed the first test,
it is now time to start your lug training.
Sorry.
That just sounds like the music and every
fucking awesome karate movie that you
watch and it makes you want to get in
shape and start punching would then you
realize it hurts the quit. Um, all right.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
So I had Steven bro come in and he was
talking about the movie I've got to do
last year with a Ethan to
play and a Elizabeth Banks.
Um, and it came out and that
people set a bunch of Nice stuff.
I guess they liked the work that I didn't,
they said I was funny.
Thank God and I appreciate that.
So, uh, if you get a chance,
you got some money to spend at checkout,
walk of shame.
And if you don't want to go to the
movies because you have a great year own
entertainment system, you can actually
download it off iTunes immediately.
It's the new way they're going to do
movies, which I think is brilliant.
It makes me want to
upgrade my system at home.
Fucking perfect download. It's like
six bucks or something like that.
Costs you less money. You don't
have to go anywhere. Pop it in.
Support the podcast, my career and
the friends I worked with. Come on.
Do we solid Cinco de Mayo.
Everybody watch walk of shame.
All right. Here's the next one.
Balding at 19 Dear Bill Emoji.
I don't know what that means.
Did I say it right?
You guys just just tripped me
up right and left this week.
First I'd like to apologize
for my English. Dude.
You're fucking English is amazing already.
I know.
I can't say first I'd like to apologize
for my French and I've been working on
this shit for over a month. It's
Spanish. I can't even, I suck at it.
You'll tango Pero Pero I say it right now.
Fuck it.
I think first I'd like to
apologize for my English.
Since it's not my native language.
I hope this won't give you difficulties
reading out loud because that would
really make the podcast lose its momentum.
You being sarcastic.
This happens every week. Um, anyway. I
am a 19 year old male and I'm balding.
For a long time I hadn't noticed
because I had longer hair.
When I recently got my haircut,
I discovered my hair had started
thinning a long time ago.
How the fuck do I deal with this?
Girls will often call me attractive,
but I know I'm not attractive in
a very masculine way, so buzzing.
It would hardly make
me feel like a bad ass.
I probably have a Dick shaped skull
hiding under my thinning main anyways.
Oh. Anyways, so that would make me
look extra ridiculous. Besides that,
I feel like I'm at an age when my hair
is still a big part of my identity and
losing it feels like Lou and losing
it feels like losing it away.
Oh, it feels like losing a way
to express myself in some way.
Losing hair at a young age like this
feels like a one way ticket to mediocrity.
Always being one step behind the rest.
For the rest of my life.
What's your advice on this since you
don't exactly have your axle rose Maine
anymore either.
Thanks for the podcast. I love
just showing Amsterdam. Oh,
well thanks for coming out.
I'd love to going to Amsterdam.
It was a privilege to come to your
country and do my little fucking dance.
Um, all right. Uh,
your fucking feelings are natural.
Especially at 19 when I first figured
out I was losing my hair and my early
thirties, I freaked the fuck
out. I couldn't believe it. Like,
how could this happen to me? I was
like, Nancy Kerrigan. I just said,
Dan will go, why, why, why?
And then, uh, as I always
do, I just fucking go. All
this is the situation.
I can either sit here and act like a
fucking bitch or I cannot try to find the
positive. And I was just like, I, I
always, this is what I always try to do.
I just look for people who are in my
situation or worse that succeeded.
And that's how I think about,
I immediately just looked at
fucking guys like Ed Harris,
Woody Harrelson.
I'm like,
they're still leads in movies and still
crushing it and getting nominated for.
So, you know, if I want to
let it stop me, it will,
um, who gives a fuck? Uh, why you
got a whole bunch of options now?
You know, you can even try and fight it
or you can just say fuck it like I did.
Um, you know, I've just
fine just giving it to,
I just find a given into
it is way fucking easier.
It's just easier to just like, all right,
well I guess I'm going to be that guy.
I'll be the friend in the movie. I
won't be the lead. So who gives a fuck?
You know, he's still in the movie. I know
you don't do that for fucking living.
Okay.
First of all I would say,
but as far as like buzzing your head like
you have no idea what you had looked.
So I can tell you do it and you might
as well fucking do it. It's a fucking,
it's great having a shaved head.
Um,
I would fucking just see what it
looks like and maybe it looks cool.
And then the, here's the deal,
if you, if you bald young,
this is how you catch up is if you keep,
if you stay in shape,
because most people,
um,
it's an absolute shit show by the
time that 35, my balding at 19. Yeah,
that's gonna fucking suck.
But this is the thing you like women
really respect confidence and if you carry
yourself and you just make jokes
about you fucking hairline,
you have a sense of humor about it. Like
there's something about it that, I dunno,
women really respond to that.
I mean other guys will still
break your balls or whatever,
but like they just fucking respond to
it because it's a great character trait
that you're, you're, you have a
sense of humor about it. You're,
you're dealing with, you
know, some form of adversity.
You're not being a pussy and letting
it drag it down. Like, oh my God,
it's making me start to think
that it's actually serious.
I never get phone calls.
BOMP bomp bomp bomp bomp
bomp bomp bomp bomp bomp
if I have a host of late night fucking,
I can read your mind
shell.
This is going to be the music.
Okay?
I look all mysterious and
I'll have like eyeliner. Um,
yeah. Your whole thing. Like I feel like
it's a one way ticket to mediocrity. Uh,
the one way ticket to mediocrity is
believing that you're on the road to a one
way ticket to mediocrity. Um, you know,
fortunately, uh, women are way more
forgiving of physical flaws then guys are,
um, so dude, you're 19 years old. Uh,
just stay in shape and go
out and crush it. Talk Shit.
Fucking hit on women that are
allegedly way out of your league.
Just swing for the fucking fences and do
the same thing with as far as whatever
dream you have as far as the,
your dream job.
Just absolutely swing out of your fucking
shoes every time you get an at bat.
And you know, honestly, dude,
if you fucking hairlines
going to stop you, I mean,
Jesus Christ. Okay? You better than
that. You're better than that comment.
You're over there in Europe. You probably
can speak more than one language.
There's no fucking reason.
Hairline or no hairline that you shouldn't
be out there just fucking crushing it.
And if you don't,
you have no one to blame but yourself.
And I'm not being hard on you.
I'm just letting you know
that you have all the power.
You hold your fucking destiny in
your hand. All right? And they go,
and here's the upside. You're only
19. By the time you fucking 30.
God knows what they'll have. If you
want to have a comeback, you know,
that's what I'm doing. I'm a hold it
out by the time I'm like fucking 60,
they're going to have the cure,
but by then who gives a fuck?
I'm 60 and then I think it will
actually be cool. It's like,
it's like having a civil war,
fucking facial hair, except you not,
if you're not a fucking hipster,
you actually fought in the civil war.
I'll be that bald guy.
I'll be the last one.
Um, yeah. I recently just buzzed my
head down and I, I grew it back out.
I busted initially and then I got an
acting work and they wanted me to grow it
out a little bit. And then the
next couple of years I kept it
and um, yeah, so you lose you. Hey,
just like what is the
fucking point of this shit?
Keep going to get a haircut and
paying for a full fucking haircut.
This is bullshit. These people, that dog
in it, there's not enough up there. So
he just buzz it down and it's
just, I don't know. I like it. I,
especially in the business I am,
I am 100% of the v of the viewpoint
of not thinking what do they want more
coming with. This is what I look like and
I get it. If you don't want to cast me,
you know, how am I going
to, I'm never going to know.
It's because of my hairline.
I'm never going, they're not going to
call me about Jews to let you know.
I'm just going to think I didn't
get the fucking park. But you know,
you just keep looking at, you fucking
look in. Either they hire you,
you don't fuck up. But at
the end of the day, the word,
if say I never get another
acting job because of that,
then all I do is tell jokes in theaters
for the rest of my fucking life.
I mean I won. So fuck it.
And how did I win Sir?
Cause I went after my dream,
my dream job too.
So that's what the fuck you should do.
And as you get older,
I'm telling you the big thing
is not going to be your hair.
It's going to be that you don't
have man tits. You don't have like
you body does it look like the
aftermath of a fucking mud slide.
That is something that they're,
you know, you need literally,
I dunno,
I don't know how you make a comeback
from that. It gets to the point
where it's so fucking stretched out.
Oh and I'll make it fat. People feel bad.
I mean they have operations for that,
which looked better than hair plugs.
I'm just saying what happened to just
fucking don't come at me with that
negative shit that made
me sad to read that,
that you feel that shit about
yourself. All right, fucking, you know,
go have some probiotics and do some
pushups. You'll be fine. You'll be fine.
All right. There you go.
All right. My New Lady,
my new lady. Hey bill birth.
I have a major problem.
My New Lady of about three months
has opened a can of worms on me.
We're both in our mid thirties.
Never been married and have no kids.
Uh,
you know,
I don't know why that just remind me
of a joke in my act that I wanted to do
that it had to do with watching women
doing floor exercises at the gym to write
this down.
Floor exercises and there you go.
I'm done writing the joke.
That's how I write people.
I'll write that and I'll write it on a
cocktail Napkin and I looked down and it
will say floor exercises and then I'll
tell the story and then it'll probably
bomb. But there'll be a couple rays
of light that I will walk towards.
And that's how it works. You liked
that? That was inside the comedy studio.
I'm sorry,
I gotta Stop Smoking cigars.
I got two more left to more Cubans
from overseas and then I am done.
I'm done.
I can't let them go to waste.
So I'm going to finish him in his fucking
done and I'm not going to smoke for a
long time.
I made the decision this morning when I
woke up and my fucking mouth tastes like
an ashtray.
And I also find when you have a bunch of
Cuban cigars and he just starts smoking
them all the time, you don't,
they don't taste as good anymore.
They just tastes like a cigar.
So it's like having steak every night.
So I need to fuck off with that
because it's a really bad habit.
All right. Having said that, I just bought
a humor door yesterday. Ah, Jesus. Bill,
if I can pick a sentence fence. All
right. My New Lady. Um, all right.
We're both in our mid thirties and
never been married and have no kids. Uh,
she's bright, sexy, funny, and
quite wealthy. I love her. Uh,
she comes from an Irish American
descent and her first name is,
am I going to say what her first
name is? Uh, no problem. So as far,
yeah.
Okay. No problem so far
you say true. However,
two weeks ago we were
enjoying each other's company
having sex over there and my
new lady whispered.
Okay.
Oh No.
Oh my God. Oh Jesus. All right,
you guys at work right now?
You guys at work?
Turn this up a little bit cause you're
not going to want to miss this. Okay?
Turn around, look around your cubicle.
Make sure the boss isn't coming.
Turn your raw open for business.
Sign to close.
All right. I usually don't name names
and I got a name the name. Okay.
Her name is Bernadette. Okay. And I'm
only saying that because this is pivotal.
She goes,
however,
two weeks ago we were enjoying each
other's company and my new lady whispered
basically during sex that bur
B e r short for Bernadette.
Okay.
Would like it up the ass.
That's what she said. [inaudible]
would like it up the ass. Oh wait,
did you think of me then?
Oh No. That's hilarious.
Oh Shit.
He goes delighted with the opportunity.
I assumed the position and an
awful thoughts suddenly struck me.
Burger is for now.
It's the same.
Yes.
The bar at my problems began.
Oh No,
you didn't have a performance
problem, did you? He goes,
I can only picture your redheaded freckled
face looking over a shoulder that at
me.
I tried mushing her face into the pillow.
Bowman in my mind all I could hear
your muffle Bostonian Twang shouting,
go fuck yourself. This is killing
me now. And it's stuck in my head.
Every time we get friendly or anytime
I call, I call her [inaudible].
Your face pops in my mind. I'm going
crazy. What can, can you suggest?
Should I just dumper? Go
Fuck Yourself. Oh God,
yeah.
You ruined my name for me.
What do you do?
First of all,
stop listening to my comedy and my
podcast immediately cold Turkey.
And then second of all,
I guess you got to fucking decide.
Yeah,
I, this is what I would
say. Two. I say, listen,
you've got to stop referring to yourself.
Is that name?
I would just be honest with it. Listen,
I gotta tell you something. All right.
Yeah.
You don't, when you said bird
would like it up the ass,
like
it is good to tell the fucking story.
Oh my God. That's the creepiest
fucking email I've ever read.
Jesus Christ. Dude, I
really feel bad for you,
but it's also fucking funny as hell. I'm
sorry I'm wrong. Ruining your sex life.
Um, yeah, man. You got to
stop listening to the podcast.
I don't know what that would do.
Oh my God.
Do you know what that
reminded me of one time? Uh,
you have a day that you have a data or
go out with a girl that has the same
first name as your mother.
I mean, any, it doesn't,
you've the first thing when
you're younger, you go, oh,
she has the same name as my mom.
Maybe this is meant to be, you know,
I loved my mother. Maybe I'll love
this woman. Maybe she's the one,
and then the first time you having
sex and you go to say their name,
it's just like, it's
over. It's fucking over.
Yeah.
So, uh, I don't know what to
tell you, dude. Jesus Christ.
If I knew I don't read these things
before I fucking look at these things.
If I knew that one was coming,
I would have closed on that one.
I don't know how to, how do you
follow that one? You know what?
I'll tell you how you follow it with
an email. Trans gender athletes.
Uh, hey Billy beer belly. Ah, I
fucking hate how fucking true that is.
I'm a lady listener on your podcast.
Ah, thank God a woman wrote in Jesus,
I wish you guys would do that more often
to try to balance this out. He goes,
I'm a lady listener of your podcast and
think your opinions are often really
honest and truthful. Why do I sense an a
fucking uppercut coming? So I was hoping,
hoping you could give your opinion
on something. All right. She said,
I just started getting really interested
in Trans Rights transgender athletes.
Right,
okay.
And have become a major advocate for the
lovely people that ended up having to
fight such a difficult uphill battle.
Um,
I am definitely convinced that
trans people, why does she,
why does she have like a
fucking Asterik next to it?
Trans people really should be allowed
to be the gender they identify with,
identify as without discrimination.
But the issue is still hard for me to
grasp is that of trans athletes competing
in professional sports.
It seemed like it could be unfortunate.
It seems like it could unfortunately be
an unfair advantage for the Trans woman.
Meaning they were born
with male genitalia,
but identify as a woman because of their
extra testosterone and bigger build.
I am really conflicted on the issue and
wonder what you think. Yeah, I definitely,
yeah. There was a while ago, there
was a dude who wanted to be a woman,
became a woman and he was a professional
tennis player and he just started
crushing it on the female, like
whatever. He was ranked as a guy.
He was ranked way higher. And uh,
yeah, I don't think that that's fair.
MMM.
But there's not enough of them
to start their own league.
So I don't know what you do. Maybe
they should start their own. Um,
why don't they start their own like
NFL or something transgender NFL.
Is that bad?
I don't understand. Like the
women's started w NBA one
don't they started trend.
That's that. Maybe that's
the solution. You got the,
I have a dick and always had one
and want to continue having one.
And then you have the, I have
a VAD, I'm happy with it.
You have both those leagues and then
you could have another leak. You know,
I'm a seeker.
That'd be a good name for a team.
Write the fucking Omaha seekers.
Why not?
And I think the biggest problem with the
league was figuring out when to air it
so you could get some TV time
now then you just have the
fucking transgendered. Oprah.
You don't start his, her own
fucking network. I mean it's just,
it's just fucking sitting there.
I think the big problem that a lot
of people make is they try to go, uh,
when you doing something
that different is you try to,
you're so hooked on the main stream,
Mike,
I want to be accepted. The way somebody
who isn't transgender is accepted,
like walking around.
That should be the deal.
But like there's actually something
to be said for being, uh, you know,
to not be in mainstream.
I mean,
there's a bunch of bands that aren't
mainstream that have this underground
following that make a really good living.
I mean,
I'll make an a great living as a comedian.
I don't have a fucking TV show.
Never had one, you know, so I guess
why, you know, you could, you could start,
you could start your own shit and then if
you start your own shit and you own it,
like Dana White, I dunno, that's
how I was looking at shit.
I never look at it like, Hey, let's
join the thing that already exists.
It already exists.
So shit is set in stone.
The fuck overs are already in there.
And the people getting paid,
I mean you gotta you gotta you know,
he got to spill some blood now that try
to fucking change it or he could just
start your own shit. Right? Like the AFL,
who knows? One day he gets so successful
they try to buy out. I Dunno. Anyways,
where am I going here?
A Mam MMA fighter.
Fallon Fox is an example of a trans
woman who is trying to compete
professionally.
If you want a reference.
Oh yeah, yeah. See now
that's the kind of thing,
I mean that that is like
an unfair advantage.
I mean,
you know,
you're removing all right the dude's Dick,
but not as shoulders.
That is kind of fucked up then.
Cause then it,
it's like a dickless dude is
beating the shit out of a woman.
Ask Him. But it's not like a
domestic violence. It's a fight.
I don't know.
And I,
and I would say every woman in the m m
m m m a I can say this with confidence
could kick my ass with ease.
Um,
so maybe it isn't, I don't fucking
know. I don't know what else. It's,
you know what it is?
It's brand new.
So we got to fucking throw them in
the mix and see how it all settles.
They go kind of copped out on that one.
I don't have any fucking solutions.
Sometimes.
I think you guys asked me this shit just
as fucking watch me talk myself into a
God damn corner.
So there you go.
It's an hour and 31 fucking minute
podcast. I don't know how that happened,
but somewhere in there I tried to solve
the problems in Israel and transgender
sports and uh,
and then there was that other
email. Jesus. All right,
that's the end of this podcast. Everybody,
uh, if you'd like to contribute to the,
you can always go to a billboard.com and
you can click on the podcast page and
if you want to buy something on Amazon,
click on the Amazon banner
will take you right there.
Buy something on Amazon and they'll kick
me a link for driving traffic to this
site. Uh, that is it. I'm going
to be in San Diego this weekend.
We just added this date. As I'm
getting ready for my a standup special.
I will give you the city. Um, cause
it looks like it might have changed.
It might not have changed. I don't know.
Shit is kind of up in the air, but the,
the first couple of weeks of June,
it's going down and we might,
I might have ticket information
by the end of this. Uh, this,
uh, this week. So look for it on Twitter
and on Facebook. All right, that's it.
Go Fuck Yourself. I'll talk
to you next week. Bye. Bye.